sigue la guerra contra el dengue en el
día internacional de la lucha contra
esta enfermedad mortal se recordó que el
virus transmitido por el mosquito aedes
agypti no se ha ido lo peor es que los
casos tuvieron estos últimos años y con
el coronavirus se complicaron los
diagnósticos en tres la impresión es que
los casos de dengue se están diluyendo
dentro del propio kobe porque muchas
veces la sintomatología es similar como
dolor en el cuerpo fiebre dolor de
cabeza en brasil se pronostica que entre
2022 y 2023 los casos de dengue aumenten
significativamente
para poder luchar contra la
proliferación del mosquito aedes agypti
hay prevenciones básicas pero desde hace
unos años se implementó en 11 países la
bacteria wolbachia entre colonias de
mosquitos que tiene como propósito
impedir la transmisión del virus un
mosquito que además de transmitir el
dengue también transmite el cica el
chikungunya y la fiebre amarilla en
indonesia donde se implementó la
bacteria se anunció en junio que los
casos locales de dengue se habían
reducido en un 77 por ciento una
esperanza para luchar contra esta
enfermedad que infecta cada año a más de
50 millones de personas en el mundo
tienen tropical indígena como país
tropical indonesia cuenta con varias
zonas donde viven que se volvió un
problema permanente
después llegó el cob y entonces es una
doble condena para los habitantes de
esta región
estas dos enfermedades pueden ser
mortales mitos a más ama
lo que preocupa más a los expertos es el
crecimiento de casos entre los niños más
vulnerables frente al virus según el
reciente índice de riesgo climático de
los niños de unicef 115 millones de
niños están expuestos a la enfermedad